she was the custodian on my college
account and I was supposed to go to ASU
and he's like we have to go to the bank
we go to the bank and I'm pleading with
the teller I'm like I need this money I
have to give ASU a deposit she's like
what and I was like I'm going to college
it's my college fund and she was like
honey there's $16 in this account no how
much was supposed to be in there
uh a lot it's all gone it's all gone she
took it and enough for me to pay for
college and it was gone
and and who had been putting that in
there for you me it was so that's not
even your dad that's your own money save
so she forced me into like childhood
modeling when I was younger so it was
like all the money from that all the
money I had been getting from relatives
throughout the years like for birthdays
everything it was my account it was my
money it was what I was supposed to
launch me and I just started crying and
my dad just started laughing and he's
like sheing got
you he's like she got you